dark side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some consider to be
unnatural welcome back everyone it's
Charlie these are gonna be my Star Wars
rise of Skywalker Easter eggs hopefully
you've had a chance to see the movie
we're doing a new round of that Star
Wars merge giveaway because they finally
have baby Yoda merch on sale all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Easter Egg from
the movie on the video big spoiler
warning if you have not seen the movie
yet because we'll be talking about all
the details the end of the movie
everything starting with number 20 the
opening crawl there's so much
information and plot that they convey in
that opening crawl the message that it
references that Palpatine sent out is
actually something that you could have
only seen inside fortnight there was a
special fortnight integration that the
Star Wars people did where they
broadcast Palpatine's message within
fortnight so you actually had to play
fortnight to watch the clip of Palpatine
revealing himself to the galaxy that he
was back but the other big easter egg
within the opening crawl is that it
refers to Palpatine as a phantom who has
returned as in a call back to the
Phantom Menace The Phantom Menace title
was about Palpatine in the Sith coming
back next big one the planet where kylo
Ren found the Sith wayfinder at the
beginning of the movie is just part of
the opening sequence is on mu stefarr if
that wasn't clear obviously we've been
there a couple times before during
Revenge of the Sith I have the high
ground and also during rogue one where
we saw
Darth Vader's castle that he later built
after he became Darth Vader the Sith
wayfinders themselves are actually based
on the classic Sith holocrons from the
comics in the expanded materials once
kylo Ren gets 2x ago Palpatine reveals
that Snoke has been a clone this whole
time there's a giant tank full of smokes
so a lot of the deformities you can
chalk up to cloning heirs because the
ones that are just chilling out in the
tank kind of seem like rejects like
these were failed attempts to clone
Snoke and the one that we saw during
last Jedi was just the most recent
successful attempt or semi successful
there's also a line of dialogue from
Palpatine where he says the darkside
leads to abilities that others may
consider unnatural a reference to the
Palpatine conversation at the Opera with
Anakin back during Revenge of the Sith
have you ever heard the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the wise when we go
the Millennium Falcon with Finn Poe in
Chewbacca they're playing a game ode to
Jarek on the board just like during a
new hope when Rey is training with her
lightsaber on the obstacle course she
uses a similar fighting style to Emperor
Palpatine a lot of people noticed this
back during last Jedi and even earlier
when she was swinging his saber around
her style seems amazingly similar to the
style the Emperor Palpatine used during
Revenge of the Sith in his lightsaber
fights the combat remote that she's
using is the same one that Luke used on
the Millennium Falcon during a new hope
and their her levitating the rocks and
herself is also a callback to Empire
Strikes Back when Luke was training with
Yoda she tries to communicate with four
spirits which they then bring back at
the end of the film that's almost like a
whole separate video I'll talk about
some of the biggest cameos but there
were over 25 different Jedi cameos in
that scene when she says I am all the
Jedi when they go to the festival at the
desert of personna c-3po says it takes
place every 42 years it is now in real
life 42 years after the debut of Star
Wars a new hope
Lando Calrissian says I got a bad
feeling about this they revealed there's
a whole deleted subplot with his
character being the father of Jonah and
her being this long-lost child who was
stolen by the first order but they had
to get rid of it because they didn't
have time for it in the movie they're
going to cover it in one of the novels
but if you thought that Jonna was
Lando's daughter you are correct
she is the brand-new droid do that shows
up on the Jedi hunter ship is voiced by
JJ Abrams the director then when they
fall down into the caves and Rey uses
her for stealing on that giant sandworm
for stealing is actually an ability that
showed up during the games in some of
the expanded material and now has also
shown up on one of the TV shows no
spoilers for the TV shows if you have
not been keeping up with the brand-new
live-action TV shows one of the next big
cameos is during Cugini when they go
into that bar John Williams himself the
composer who's done the music for all
the Star Wars films is the bartender he
has a bunch of face prosthetics on but
he's pretty identifiable when they try
to read the Sith wayfinder they have to
wipe c-3po s mind the last time he got
his mind wiped was at the end of the
prequels somebody wiped those two droids
minds even though technically he gets
his memory back by the end of the film
they find out that they have to go back
to the second Death Star obviously
direct reference to Return of the Jedi
the wreckage but she uses a special
knife in the map to find a special
room next to the Emperor's throne they
try to linger a lot when she's walking
around the imperial throne room because
later in the movie Emperor Palpatine
says you could be Empress Palpatine so
they wanted you to have that image in
your mind remembering her on that second
Death Star near the throne when she sees
the dark version of herself that's
obviously just a force vision but she's
using a double bladed lightsaber just
like the temple guards from the animated
series a lot of people wondering about
that weird hinge that's actually
something that has shown up in Star Wars
before when she enters the Emperor's
throne room on that Death Star they also
start playing John Williams original
score from Return of the Jedi
when Rey goes back to auch - it's meant
to be a bit of a mirror for Luke
Skywalker going to auch - in getting rid
of his x-wing by burying it in the water
Rey tries to destroy the TIE fighter
then just like Luke tossed Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber over his shoulder
she tries to toss it into the fire to
destroy it we see his Force Coast for
the first time in the movie he catches
it letting you know that force ghost can
physically interact with the real world
but they also give him a joke about the
opening scene of last Jedi referencing
that when he says you should respect the
weapon of a Jedi when she finally gets
her [ __ ] together
Luke lifts his old x-wing out of the
water just like Yoda and they play
Yoda's theme song from john williams
wallace happening
when rain kylo Ren fight she winds up
killing him then healing him and taking
off in his tie fighter kylo Ren then
slowly turns back into Ben's solo but
now without the efforts of Leia who's
projecting herself in creating this
vision of Han Solo so part of the reason
why han Solo was standing here talking
to him and they do the big callback to
the Starkiller base in the moment that
he killed him referencing a lot of that
stuff it's actually Leia that's making
this happen when he's talking to Han
Solo though he gets ready to say dad I
love you but Han Solo as you would
expect stops him short and says I know
direct reference to Empire Strikes Back
when Leia said I love you when the final
battle begins and all the ships jump
into the planet around EXA goal and the
imperial fleet with their new Star
Destroyers are rising up their classic
imperial star destroyers not the new
first-order ones the reason why they're
so dangerous is because they've been
retrofitted with miniaturized versions
of the Death Star laser you zoom in the
30 years since Return of the Jedi they
found a way to miniaturize that
technology
there are a bunch of cameos during this
scene they bring back older wedge
antilles from the original series where
he calls in Rey is also flying read five
Luke Skywalker's original x-wing within
the giant fleet though that giant shot
you see in the trailer the ghost from
Star Wars rebels shows up there's really
pretty much every type of ship you've
ever seen in the Star Wars movie or any
of the TV shows showing up in that fleet
there's even a ship that looks a little
bit like the Razr crest down here from
the Mandalorian although no confirmation
that any kind of Mandalorian stuff is
happening during rise of Skywalker I
know everybody wants to know where's
baby Yoda apparently not in the movie
that's where when they start to fight
Emperor Palpatine he says to Ben solo
you two shall fall if just as I once did
and literally throws him down the hole
like he got thrown down a hole by Darth
Vader
speaking of Palpatine when he talks
about cloning and transferring his
essence like Rey has to kill him he'll
enter her body and she will become the
future of the Sith Empress Palpatine or
he'll just straight-up take over her
body if she doesn't wanna have anything
to do with it that's a direct reference
to a lot of the expanded material
especially the dark empire comics there
was a subplot where he tried to clone
himself and would enter new bodies every
time he died but also during that
storyline Leia was pregnant with her
twins that she had in the comics in the
expanded universe Palpatine was also
planning on transferring his force
essence into the unborn child in Leia's
womb that's why he was so interested in
Leia during that comic book so he's
basically telling Rey the same thing I'm
going to enter your body and either
you're going to take over or I'm going
to take over you this is lightning on
steroids that he uses to destroy a lot
of the fleet is also something from the
dark empire comic where he uses what you
would call super lightning to destroy a
bunch of ships in space Rey is also able
to deflect the Lightning back on to him
just like mace windu did using the light
sabers but also when this is happening
you start to hear a chorus of Jedi cameo
voices coming back to the movie I might
do a separate video for all of them
because there were so many there are
over 25 but here are some of the biggest
ones Hayden Christensen came back as
Anakin Skywalker telling her bring
balance to the force as I once did
Luminara comes back ahsoka tano comes
back JJ Abrams even hinted that she was
coming back earlier turns out it was as
a voiceover cameo meaning that she's
dead we'll have to talk about that too
at some point because
when did ahsoka die samuel l.jackson
comes back as mace windu and then two
different versions of obi-wan Kenobi
both you and McGregor's version and they
bring back the Alec Guinness version you
all probably heard Yoda's voice and they
bring back Liam Neeson as qui-gon jinn
one of the first people in the movies
that started talking about becoming a
force ghost and learning that ability
even though technically he himself never
fully learned how to do it they dressed
a lot of that during the animated Clone
Wars series where he helps teach Yoda
how to become a force ghost so that when
he eventually dies during Return of the
Jedi
he becomes a force ghost I know that a
lot of questions about force ghost
because Ben solo gives the rest of his
life force to bring ray back because she
dies so he gives the last of his life
force she comes back but she doesn't
have enough to top him back up so he
winds up dying and then disappears
turning into a force ghost himself a
long time ago the rule used to be you
actually had to specially-trained with
people to learn how to become a force
ghost but when all Jedi's die their life
force transfers back into the greater
living force but when you learn to
become a force ghost you essentially
learn how to retain your identity when
you become pure energy like that they
have their big celebration just like at
the end of each different Star Wars
trilogy it wouldn't be a Star Wars
trilogy if they didn't have a giant
party all over the galaxy at the very
end they even go back to Endor and show
you a couple a walks one of them being
played by Warwick Davis himself who
played wicked during Return of the Jedi
when Rey goes back to Tatooine and the
large family moisture farm to bury the
lightsabers she sits on a piece of metal
and slides down the embankment just like
she did at the beginning of force
awakens while the Rey theme song plays
she buries Luke and Leia's lightsabers
which they kind of explained earlier in
the film Leia at one point did train to
be a Jedi made a lightsaber but short of
completing her training since that Ben
Solo had been tempted by the dark side
in the fact that her son could fall just
shook her so badly she had to stop and
gave Luke her lightsaber for a later
time they confirmed that there's been a
bit of a time jump because she's had the
time we see to create a new lightsaber
at which he pulls out ignites we find
out that the blade is yellow and also
the hilt is made from pieces of her
staff but the other big thing that's
happening is while she's bearing these
lightsabers and having that moment where
she calls herself a Skywalker seeing
Luke and Leia's force ghost is the
the soundtrack is playing right now the
theme song is named a new home as in is
this going to be Ray's new home will she
go live on Tatooine because she seems to
like the desert so much no confirmation
on that but the idea is that she has the
Jedi text so she's probably going to be
making a new jedi temple of her own
seeking out other force people which
includes finn who is force sensitive
during this movie JJ Abrams just came
out in the past couple of days and said
the thing that finn was trying to tell
ray throughout the movie but couldn't
was that he was force sensitive and was
feeling things through the force like
several times he feels what's happening
to her but he's very very far away no
idea how powerful he is but he is force
sensitive and could train to become a
Jedi after a rise of Skywalker I'm sure
there's a billion more Easter eggs that
they try to cram in they tried to make
it as fanservice E as possible including
as much stuff as possible so if there
any big Easter eggs that you spotted
that I didn't include in my video just
write them below in the comments the
Mandalorian episode 8 is going to be the
finale that'll air Friday so obviously
I'll be doing videos for that there's a
bunch of Witcher Netflix stuff to drop
this week so I'll also be doing that
between Star Wars videos I'll name a new
giveaway winner the next time I post one
everyone click here for my Mandalorian
episode 7 video and click here for my
Star Wars rise of Skywalker top 20 WTF
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you